SCP-173 Vs SCP-106. The Sinister,
Neck-Snapping Sculpture Vs The Old Man
with the Plan to Torture You Forever.
This is an incredibly close call, with
both being immensely powerful anomalies.
SCP-173 is one of the few
creatures SCP-682 is terrified of,
and its ability to snap necks with little effort
and incredible speed make it a formidable foe.
But 106 may just have the edge here.
Firstly, we don’t even know if 106 has eyelids,
so he might not ever blink. Secondly, his
powers make him able to phase through and
also corrupt solid objects, which SCP-173 may
be vulnerable to. And most compelling of all,
there’s no telling what SCP-173 would make of
being trapped in the Old Man’s pocket dimension.
For all these reasons, we think 106 would
walk away with the title belt this time!